damage dealt that's me baby
there's a lot of donuts over there josh
the biggest bot today
is josh hart
[Music]
[Applause]
what's good everybody my name is
christopher london and today
i am joined with the one the only
josh hart that's good josh what's up my
boy
josh is quite the gamer i'm quite the
gamer but today we are going to put that
game to the test
and right now we've we've upgraded our
uh gaming setups you know
i've got the omen desktop but with the
rgb
lighting now i have my desktop with the
purple lighting i don't know what it is
but just
my vibe and josh has the nice thin omen
laptop josh talk to me about that laptop
man that thing looks
sleek yeah bro it's perfect for me
because obviously being in the nba we
travel so much with away games
in and out of hotels obviously there's
so many ups and downs of the season
so many stressful points several moments
so for me my kind of escape my kind of
thing to kind of wind down and unwind
is just gaming i agree and that's what
play to progress is
all about we're just gonna hop
right into this first game man let's do
it we're gonna hop
into valerie hey we gotta work together
here
speaking of teammates who is your
favorite teammate
right now my favorite oh right now
that's tough me and jj ready probably we
get along very well you know
he was staying in the crib for a little
bit
let me get that easy cow let's go i'll
take it thank you
let's go all right so guys
i want to test josh's video game
knowledge
with the omen gamer brain quiz
question number one there are a million
quests on your mini map
i'm feeling stressed i'm feeling stoked
i think i'm i'm getting a little
stressed here because that's a that's a
lot of questions
no one's no one you're not getting
stoked with a million quests
oh above above me oh yeah
headshot baby all right the boss dropped
the loop
what are you picking up the flaming
battle axe or the mysterious one
i think i'm gonna go with the the battle
axe we're going with the pawn bro it's
mysterious
let's go diffuse let's go
watch out let's go i clutch that baby
last question josh red alert
the enemy comes at dawn i gather my best
generals and make a plan
i follow my gut and start issuing orders
i was following my gut man i got to get
all the glory you know all the girls
my results were the road all right
my brain strengths are stealthy
effective
and intimidating i'm the muse
inspiring creative and charismatic oh
okay i'm a little inspiring you know
[Music]
i'm coming
[Music]
[Applause]
i got a question who's the better gamer
out of you and i today
i'll say that today chris london
was the best gamer no everyone has their
bad days or all day
so chris capitalized on my just
and uh sorry uh i'm just allergic to
excuses
excuses josh he was camping bro
no i don't want to hear it i'mma need to
get my hands
on that omen laptop like you're not
getting mine brother
i can't get yours but hopefully yeah
[Music]
brother